The second thing is what the story,
the creation stories in genesis,
for example,
actually need because they actually mean
something and what they mean is
absolutely remarkable in my estimation.
And so I'm going to tell you a little
bit about that story because it's
necessary to understand what the story
means to determine if what Nisha said
about the inevitable destruction of our
symbolic religious structures by science
was inevitable and necessary.
And I think the answer to that is no.
We just didn't understand what the hell
we were doing any more than we really
understand why we put up Christmas trees
at Christmas.
So we do that in part because the
Christmas tree is a symbol of life
because the tree is a symbol of life
because we inhabited trees for untold
millions of years and we put lights on
the trees to symbolize the coming back
into the darkness of Midwinter of the
Sun and the light.
And so we play this symbolic game that
celebrates both life and the emergence
of light and consciousness.
And we associate that with the birth of
the savior.
But we don't know that we're doing that.
But we do it anyways so,
and we do that sort of thing all the
time because we're smarter than we know
and that has to be the case because we
don't know ourselves.
We would need a psychology or sociology
and anthropology or any of those things.
If we were transparent to ourselves.
We're machines so to speak,
that are far more intelligent and wise.
Then the machines themselves can
understand and we've reveal ourselves to
ourselves,
you know,
our action and our symbolic gestures
constantly.
And then have to reflect on that to try
to understand what it is that we're up
to.